and then
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to my adventures at Blizzcon
I was so happy to be able to be here
because I've been wanting to go to
Blizzcon forever and I gotta thank HP
for getting me out there last minute and
paying the whole way for the costumes
for the camera and I always do cherish
these moments when I'm able to meet my
fans and meet you guys in person and
really get to know you because
everything was still organized even
though his last minute there was a
camera crew there they organized a
meet-and-greet I got to meet so many
fans and I got to play on HP's fancy new
laptop with other youtubers with other
fans it was an all-around fantastic
experience so many people were happy to
see me so many people were just playing
happy
I was so high god this guy didn't seem
as happy but in reality everyone was
awesome and I so cherished these moments
when I'm able to meet you guys and I
can't wait for the next opportunity I
think being in costume was cool and all
but I live to be able to help you guys
out and to be able to know that my
videos are making a difference in the
world
that's what's truly important and what
what a markiplier video be without some
derp artistic speedy transition also
Ross from the game grumps and his
channel rubber ninja was there and we
got down and dirty with some hearthstone
on the new laptops hi Ross a Maki moon
you ready to go down what are you doing
Oh watch this your hexing me that you're
done you're done son no stop
i won wait wait we need that and then
something weird started happening with
my eyebrows I couldn't control them they
were just rampant on my face I just
couldn't stop no matter what I tried it
here's Ross's wife Holly who was an
amazing cosplayer come on let's play all
right ready
no well you cast it on yourself dude you
those good strategy I'm standing on my
dress it's a robe no if
to dress I can't even say I'm sorry hey
look some fans okay time to act normal
look at that oh you get the tiny and
adorable camera clacker thingy
okay here's Justin Flynn let's see if
the eyebrow treatment works on him
okay Justin Flynn I'll let you pick how
you give me all right no my mother lucky
oh I feel like I'm just taking the upper
hand no my ire just finish me I'm trying
it's not fair I tells you it's not fair
that doesn't seem to be phasing him but
oh hey it's a fan look this is Cody
how's it going can I win okay fine
here's Vernon of hot pepper gaming about
to be destroyed for revenge here's a
cool statue here's a fan and here's a
guy named Ian another fan that destroyed
me so badly it shook me to my core but I
got to be in this cool thing called the
Bliss cam which produced this amazing
video awesome hey last words
and here's Cragen you killed the pig I
did I killed the pig nobody nice yeah oh
yeah oh my god my spasm my eyebrows I
couldn't stop it I couldn't stop it at
all but then again maybe it was because
of this inexplicable shot of stripping
that the cameraman got of his crotch so
thank you all so much for an amazing
Blizzcon adventure I have actually never
been to Blizzcon and I wanted to thank
HP for sending me out there last minute
they organized this whole thing they got
me in costume they got me this big crew
and maker and I never cosplayed before
so it was actually a cool experience to
be able to do that I was a blood elf and
I was a priest and I've been playing
wild forever so I know about that stuff
but I've always wanted to go to Blizzcon
and I met so many of you people even
though I was incognito unable to like
traverse the crowd without anyone
spotting me you guys just blink out of
the blue beeline straight for me hey
more good cos to minimally okay thanks
hi I had a put on her big elf ears no it
didn't matter it was awesome so I just
wanted to say thank you so much all they
wanted in return was
for me to make the video that you just
saw with their new laptop which is this
one here the omen I want to be very
clear that they're not paying me to
review this in any way all opinions
about this machine are my own that being
said this thing is awesome
this thing is ridiculously cool-looking
it's very sleek it's very thin it clocks
in a little over four and a half pounds
I believe I'm not sure feels like
compared to my old one or my current one
which I think clocks in at twelve pounds
and I think it's equivalently powerful -
this one right here is a little more
it's got a nice 747 ten I believe and
then eight gigs ram in the baseline
model it's got a gtx 860m and it's got
256 gigabyte solid state disk if you
don't know what any of that means ask
someone else in the LCL never ask
someone who does know in the comments
below that being said this thing has
been able to handle everything I've
thrown at it at moderate settings I mean
with gaming laptop you need to kind of
reel in your expectations but it's still
really cool because I've wanted
something that can better handle
recording on the road oh speaking of
which I'm going to be at PAX South
that's the next events where I can meet
you guys so if you're already going or
you have an opportunity to get a badge
because I think that's sold out by now
please feel free to come down and meet
me say hi to me I may try to do a vent
where I meet up people outside of the
convention but I don't know the area so
I don't know where to go so news will be
posted about that as it comes so with
this thing I really do like it this is
going to be my next laptop and I just
wanted to say thank you to HP for
getting me out to Bliss done because
meeting you guys is very important to me
and as a tech head I love new technology
and this thing is pretty cool um did I
miss anything else
nice sorry I just leave your laptop I
have to give this one back join you
that's enough fawni over that machine so
thank you all so much for watching I
just want to be very clear that you know
I'm not trying to push this on you I'm
not trying to sell it on you I just
wanted to give my thoughts about a
really cool gadget that I was given to
use for a video and an opportunity that
I was given to meet you guys that's
what's really important so thank you for
these really cool opportunities and just
thank you so much for being there and
supporting me and just doing everything
to make my life better I can't wait to
see you guys at PAX house I can't wait
to see you guys in every gaming
convention that I have time to go to I
can't wait to be able to do more cool
stuff like this in the future so thanks
again everybody for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye
Bob you know if I was smart I duct tape
the two of these together and then I
never double ultra laptop that I'd never
be able to pick up thus
you